The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu
PROFESSOR: So we're going to
finish today our discussion of
Bayesian Inference, which
we started last time.
As you probably saw there's
not a huge lot of concepts
that we're introducing at this
point in terms of specific
skills of calculating
probabilities.
But, rather, it's more of an
interpretation and setting up
the framework.
So the framework in Bayesian
estimation is that there is
some parameter which is not
known, but we have a prior
distribution on it.
These are beliefs about what
this variable might be, and
then we'll obtain some
measurements.
And the measurements are
affected by the value of that
parameter that we don't know.
And this effect, the fact that
X is affected by Theta, is
captured by introducing a
conditional probability
distribution--
the distribution of X
depends on Theta.
It's a conditional probability
distribution.
So we have formulas for these
two densities, the prior
density and the conditional
density.
And given that we have these,
if we multiply them we can
also get the joint density
of X and Theta.
So we have everything
that's there is to
know in this second.
And now we observe the random
variable X. Given this random
variable what can we
say about Theta?
Well, what we can do is we
can always calculate the
conditional distribution of
theta given X. And now that we
have the specific value of
X we can plot this as
a function of Theta.
OK.
And this is the complete
answer to a
Bayesian Inference problem.
This posterior distribution
captures everything there is
to say about Theta, that's
what we know about Theta.
Given the X that we have
observed Theta is still
random, it's still unknown.
And it might be here, there,
or there with several
probabilities.
On the other hand, if you want
to report a single value for
Theta then you do
some extra work.
You continue from here, and you
do some data processing on
X. Doing data processing means
that you apply a certain
function on the data,
and this function is
something that you design.
It's the so-called estimator.
And once that function is
applied it outputs an estimate
of Theta, which we
call Theta hat.
So this is sort of the big
picture of what's happening.
Now one thing to keep in mind
is that even though I'm
writing single letters here, in
general Theta or X could be
vector random variables.
So think of this--
it could be a collection
Theta1, Theta2, Theta3.
And maybe we obtained several
measurements, so this X is
really a vector X1,
X2, up to Xn.
All right, so now how do we
choose a Theta to report?
There are various ways
of doing it.
One is to look at the posterior
distribution and
report the value of Theta, at
which the density or the PMF
is highest.
This is called the maximum
a posteriori estimate.
So we pick a value of theta for
which the posteriori is
maximum, and we report it.
An alternative way is to try to
be optimal with respects to
a mean squared error.
So what is this?
If we have a specific estimator,
g, this is the
estimate it's going
to produce.
This is the true value of
Theta, so this is our
estimation error.
We look at the square of the
estimation error, and look at
the average value.
We would like this squared
estimation error to be as
small as possible.
How can we design our estimator
g to make that error
as small as possible?
It turns out that the answer is
to produce, as an estimate,
the conditional expectation
of Theta given X. So the
conditional expectation is the
best estimate that you could
produce if your objective is to
keep the mean squared error
as small as possible.
So this statement here is a
statement of what happens on
the average over all Theta's and
all X's that may happen in
our experiment.
The conditional expectation as
an estimator has an even
stronger property.
Not only it's optimal on the
average, but it's also optimal
given that you have made a
specific observation, no
matter what you observe.
Let's say you observe the
specific value for the random
variable X. After that point if
you're asked to produce a
best estimate Theta hat that
minimizes this mean squared
error, your best estimate
would be the conditional
expectation given the specific
value that you have observed.
These two statements say almost
the same thing, but
this one is a bit stronger.
This one tells you no matter
what specific X happens the
conditional expectation
is the best estimate.
This one tells you on the
average, over all X's may
happen, the conditional
expectation is the best estimator.
Now this is really a consequence
of this.
If the conditional expectation
is best for any specific X,
then it's the best one even when
X is left random and you
are averaging your error
over all possible X's.
OK so now that we know what is
the optimal way of producing
an estimate let's do a
simple example to see
how things work out.
So we have started with an
unknown random variable,
Theta, which is uniformly
distributed between 4 and 10.
And then we have an observation
model that tells
us that given the value of
Theta, X is going to be a
random variable that ranges
between Theta -
1, and Theta + 1.
So think of X as a noisy
measurement of Theta, plus
some noise, which is
between -1, and +1.
So really the model that we are
using here is that X is
equal to Theta plus U --
where U is uniform
on -1, and +1.
one, and plus one.
So we have the true value of
Theta, but X could be Theta -
1, or it could be all the
way up to Theta + 1.
And the X is uniformly
distributed on that interval.
That's the same as saying that
U is uniformly distributed
over this interval.
So now we have all the
information that we need, we
can construct the
joint density.
And the joint density is, of
course, the prior density
times the conditional density.
We go both of these.
Both of these are constants, so
the joint density is also
going to be a constant.
1/6 times 1/2, this
is one over 12.
But it is a constant,
not everywhere.
Only on the range of possible
x's and thetas.
So theta can take any value
between four and ten, so these
are the values of theta.
And for any given value of theta
x can take values from
theta minus one, up
to theta plus one.
So here, if you can imagine, a
line that goes with slope one,
and then x can take that value
of theta plus or minus one.
So this object here, this is
the set of possible x and
theta pairs.
So the density is equal to one
over 12 over this set, and
it's zero everywhere else.
So outside here the density is
zero, the density only applies
at that point.
All right, so now we're
asked to estimate
theta in terms of x.
So we want to build an estimator
which is going to be
a function from the
x's to the thetas.
That's why I chose the axis
this way-- x to be on this
axis, theta on that axis--
Because the estimator we're
building is a function of x.
Based on the observation that
we obtained, we want to
estimate theta.
So we know that the optimal
estimator is the conditional
expectation, given
the value of x.
So what is the conditional
expectation?
If you fix a particular value of
x, let's say in this range.
So this is our x, then what
do we know about theta?
We know that theta lies
in this range.
Theta can only be sampled
between those two values.
And what kind of distribution
does theta have?
What is the conditional
distribution of theta given x?
Well, remember how we built
conditional distributions from
joint distributions?
The conditional distribution is
just a section of the joint
distribution applied to
the place where we're
conditioning.
So the joint is constant.
So the conditional is also going
to be a constant density
over this interval.
So the posterior distribution
of theta is
uniform over this interval.
So if the posterior of theta is
uniform over that interval,
the expected value of theta is
going to be the meet point of
that interval.
So the estimate which
you report--
if you observe that theta--
is going to be this particular
point here, it's the midpoint.
The same argument goes through
even if you obtain an x
somewhere here.
Given this x, theta
can take a value
between these two values.
Theta is going to have a uniform
distribution over this
interval, and the conditional
expectation of theta given x
is going to be the midpoint
of that interval.
So now if we plot our estimator
by tracing midpoints
in this diagram what you're
going to obtain is a curve
that starts like this, then
it changes slope.
So that it keeps track of the
midpoint, and then it goes
like that again.
So this blue curve here is
our g of x, which is the
conditional expectation of
theta given that x is
equal to little x.
So it's a curve, in our example
it consists of three
straight segments.
But overall it's non-linear.
It's not a single line
through this diagram.
And that's how things
are in general.
g of x, our optimal estimate has
no reason to be a linear
function of x.
In general it's going to be
some complicated curve.
So how good is our estimate?
I mean you reported your x, your
estimate of theta based
on x, and your boss asks you
what kind of error do you
expect to get?
Having observed the particular
value of x, what you can
report to your boss is what you
think is the mean squared
error is going to be.
We observe the particular
value of x.
So we're conditioning, and we're
living in this universe.
Given that we have made this
observation, this is the true
value of theta, this is the
estimate that we have
produced, this is the expected
squared error, given that we
have made the particular
observation.
Now in this conditional universe
this is the expected
value of theta given x.
So this is the expected value of
this random variable inside
the conditional universe.
So when you take the mean
squared of a random variable
minus the expected value, this
is the same thing as the
variance of that random
variable.
Except that it's the
variance inside
the conditional universe.
Having observed x, theta is
still a random variable.
It's distributed according to
the posterior distribution.
Since it's a random variable,
it has a variance.
And that variance is our
mean squared error.
So this is the variance of the
posterior distribution of
Theta given the observation
that we have made.
OK, so what is the variance
in our example?
If X happens to be here, then
Theta is uniform over this
interval, and this interval
has length 2.
Theta is uniformly distributed
over an interval of length 2.
This is the posterior
distribution of Theta.
What is the variance?
Then you remember the formula
for the variance of a uniform
random variable, it is the
length of the interval squared
divided by 12, so this is 1/3.
So the variance of Theta --
the mean squared error-- is
going to be 1/3 whenever this
kind of picture applies.
This picture applies when
X is between 5 and 9.
If X is less than 5, then the
picture is a little different,
and Theta is going
to be uniform
over a smaller interval.
And so the variance of
theta is going to
be smaller as well.
So let's start plotting our
mean squared error.
Between 5 and 9 the variance
of Theta --
the posterior variance--
is 1/3.
Now when the X falls in here
Theta is uniformly distributed
over a smaller interval.
The size of this interval
changes
linearly over that range.
And so when we take the square
size of that interval we get a
quadratic function of
how much we have
moved from that corner.
So at that corner what is
the variance of Theta?
Well if I observe an X that's
equal to 3 then I know with
certainty that Theta
is equal to 4.
Then I'm in very good shape, I
know exactly what Theta is
going to be.
So the variance, in this
case, is going to be 0.
If I observe an X that's a
little larger than Theta is
now random, takes values on
a little interval, and the
variance of Theta is going to be
proportional to the square
of the length of that
little interval.
So we get a curve that
starts rising
quadratically from here.
It goes up forward 1/3.
At the other end of the picture
the same is true.
If you observe an X which is
11 then Theta can only be
equal to 10.
And so the error in Theta
is equal to 0,
there's 0 error variance.
But as we obtain X's that are
slightly less than 11 then the
mean squared error again
rises quadratically.
So we end up with a
plot like this.
What this plot tells us is that
certain measurements are
better than others.
If you're lucky, and you see X
equal to 3 then you're lucky,
because you know Theta
exactly what it is.
If you see an X which is equal
to 6 then you're sort of
unlikely, because it
doesn't tell you
Theta with great precision.
Theta could be anywhere
on that interval.
And so the variance
of Theta --
even after you have
observed X --
is a certain number,
1/3 in our case.
So the moral to keep out
of that story is
that the error variance--
or the mean squared error--
depends on what particular
observation
you happen to obtain.
Some observations may be very
informative, and once you see
a specific number than you know
exactly what Theta is.
Some observations might
be less informative.
You observe your X, but it could
still leave a lot of
uncertainty about Theta.
So conditional expectations are
really the cornerstone of
Bayesian estimation.
They're particularly
popular, especially
in engineering contexts.
There used a lot in signal
processing, communications,
control theory, so on.
So that makes it worth playing
a little bit with their
theoretical properties, and get
some appreciation of a few
subtleties involved here.
No new math in reality, in what
we're going to do here.
But it's going to be a good
opportunity to practice
manipulation of conditional
expectations.
So let's look at the expected
value of the estimation error
that we obtained.
So Theta hat is our estimator,
is the conditional
expectation.
Theta hat minus Theta is what
kind of error do we have?
If Theta hat, is bigger than
Theta then we have made the
positive error.
If not, if it's on the other
side, we have made the
negative error.
Then it turns out that on the
average the errors cancel each
other out, on the average.
So let's do this calculation.
Let's calculate the expected
value of the error given X.
Now by definition the error is
expected value of Theta hat
minus Theta given X.
We use linearity of expectations
to break it up as
expected value of Theta hat
given X minus expected value
of Theta given X.
And now what?
Our estimate is made on the
basis of the data of the X's.
If I tell you X then you
know what Theta hat is.
Remember that the conditional
expectation is a random
variable which is a function
of the random variable, on
which you're conditioning on.
If you know X then you know the
conditional expectation
given X, you know what Theta
hat is going to be.
So Theta hat is a function of
X. If it's a function of X
then once I tell you X
you know what Theta
hat is going to be.
So this conditional expectation
is going to be
Theta hat itself.
Here this is-- just
by definition--
Theta hat, and so we
get equality to 0.
So what we have proved is that
no matter what I have
observed, and given that I have
observed something on the
average my error is
going to be 0.
This is a statement involving
equality of random variables.
Remember that conditional
expectations are random
variables because they depend
on the thing you're
conditioning on.
0 is sort of a trivial
random variable.
This tells you that this random
variable is identically
equal to the 0 random
variable.
More specifically it tells you
that no matter what value for
X you observe, the conditional
expectation of the error is
going to be 0.
And this takes us to this
statement here, which is
inequality between numbers.
No matter what specific value
for capital X you have
observed, your error, on
the average, is going
to be equal to 0.
So this is a less abstract
version of these statements.
This is inequality between
two numbers.
It's true for every value of
X, so it's true in terms of
these random variables being
equal to that random variable.
Because remember according to
our definition this random
variable is the random variable
that takes this
specific value when capital
X happens to be
equal to little x.
Now this doesn't mean that your
error is 0, it only means
that your error is as likely, in
some sense, to fall on the
positive side, as to fall
on the negative side.
So sometimes your error will be
positive, sometimes negative.
And on the average these
things cancel out and
give you a 0 --.
on the average.
So this is a property that's
sometimes giving the name we
say that Theta hat
is unbiased.
So Theta hat, our estimate, does
not have a tendency to be
on the high side.
It does not have a tendency
to be on the low side.
On the average it's
just right.
So let's do a little
more playing here.
Let's see how our error is
related to an arbitrary
function of the data.
Let's do this in a conditional
universe and
look at this quantity.
In a conditional universe
where X is known
then h of X is known.
And so you can pull it outside
the expectation.
In the conditional universe
where the value of X is given
this quantity becomes
just a constant.
There's nothing random
about it.
So you can pull it out,
the expectation, and
write things this way.
And we have just calculated
that this quantity is 0.
So this number turns out
to be 0 as well.
Now having done this,
we can take
expectations of both sides.
And now let's use the law of
iterated expectations.
Expectation of a conditional
expectation gives us the
unconditional expectation, and
this is also going to be 0.
So here we use the law of
iterated expectations.
OK.
OK, why are we doing this?
We're doing this because I would
like to calculate the
covariance between Theta
tilde and Theta hat.
Theta hat is, ask the question
-- is there a systematic
relation between the error
and the estimate?
So to calculate the covariance
we use the property that we
can calculate the covariances
by calculating the expected
value of the product minus
the product of
the expected values.
And what do we get?
This is 0, because of
what we just proved.
And this is 0, because of
what we proved earlier.
That the expected value of
the error is equal to 0.
So the covariance between the
error and any function of X is
equal to 0.
Let's use that to the case where
the function of X we're
considering is Theta
hat itself.
Theta hat is our estimate, it's
a function of X. So this
0 result would still apply,
and we get that this
covariance is equal to 0.
OK, so that's what we proved.
Let's see, what are the morals
to take out of all this?
First is you should be very
comfortable with this type of
calculation involving
conditional expectations.
The main two things that we're
using are that when you
condition on a random variable
any function of that random
variable becomes a constant,
and can be pulled out the
conditional expectation.
The other thing that we are
using is the law of iterated
expectations, so these are
the skills involved.
Now on the substance, why is
this result interesting?
This tells us that the error is
uncorrelated with the estimate.
What's a hypothetical situation
where these would
not happen?
Whenever Theta hat is positive
my error tends to be negative.
Suppose that whenever Theta hat
is big then you say oh my
estimate is too big, maybe the
true Theta is on the lower
side, so I expect my error
to be negative.
That would be a situation that
would violate this condition.
This condition tells you that
no matter what Theta hat is,
you don't expect your error to
be on the positive side or on
the negative side.
Your error will still
be 0 on the average.
So if you obtain a very high
estimate this is no reason for
you to suspect that
the true Theta is
lower than your estimate.
If you suspected that the true
Theta was lower than your
estimate you should have
changed your Theta hat.
If you make an estimate and
after obtaining that estimate
you say I think my estimate
is too big, and so
the error is negative.
If you thought that way then
that means that your estimate
is not the optimal one, that
your estimate should have been
corrected to be smaller.
And that would mean that there's
a better estimate than
the one you used, but the
estimate that we are using
here is the optimal one in terms
of mean squared error,
there's no way of
improving it.
And this is really captured
in that statement.
That is knowing Theta hat
doesn't give you a lot of
information about the error, and
gives you, therefore, no
reason to adjust your estimate
from what it was.
Finally, a consequence
of all this.
This is the definition
of the error.
Send Theta to this side, send
Theta tilde to that side, you
get this relation.
The true parameter is composed
of two quantities.
The estimate, and the
error that they got
with a minus sign.
These two quantities are
uncorrelated with each other.
Their covariance is 0, and
therefore, the variance of
this is the sum of the variances
of these two
quantities.
So what's an interpretation
of this equality?
There is some inherent
randomness in the random
variable theta that we're
trying to estimate.
Theta hat tries to estimate it,
tries to get close to it.
And if Theta hat always stays
close to Theta, since Theta is
random Theta hat must also be
quite random, so it has
uncertainty in it.
And the more uncertain Theta
hat is the more it moves
together with Theta.
So the more uncertainty
it removes from Theta.
And this is the remaining
uncertainty in Theta.
The uncertainty that's left
after we've done our
estimation.
So ideally, to have a small
error we want this
quantity to be small.
Which is the same as
saying that this
quantity should be big.
In the ideal case Theta hat
is the same as Theta.
That's the best we
could hope for.
That corresponds to 0 error,
and all the uncertainly in
Theta is absorbed by the
uncertainty in Theta hat.
Interestingly, this relation
here is just another variation
of the law of total variance
that we have seen at some
point in the past.
I will skip that derivation, but
it's an interesting fact,
and it can give you an
alternative interpretation of
the law of total variance.
OK, so now let's return
to our example.
In our example we obtained the
optimal estimator, and we saw
that it was a nonlinear curve,
something like this.
I'm exaggerating the corner
of a little bit to
show that it's nonlinear.
This is the optimal estimator.
It's a nonlinear function
of X --
nonlinear generally
means complicated.
Sometimes the conditional
expectation is really hard to
compute, because whenever you
have to compute expectations
you need to do some integrals.
And if you have many random
variables involved it might
correspond to a
multi-dimensional integration.
We don't like this.
Can we come up, maybe,
with a simpler way
of estimating Theta?
Of coming up with a point
estimate which still has some
nice properties, it
has some good
motivation, but is simpler.
What does simpler mean?
Perhaps linear.
Let's put ourselves in a
straitjacket and restrict
ourselves to estimators that's
are of these forms.
My estimate is constrained
to be a linear
function of the X's.
So my estimator is going to be
a curve, a linear curve.
It could be this, it could be
that, maybe it would want to
be something like this.
I want to choose the best
possible linear function.
What does that mean?
It means that I write my
Theta hat in this form.
If I fix a certain a and b I
have fixed the functional form
of my estimator, and this
is the corresponding
mean squared error.
That's the error between the
true parameter and the
estimate of that parameter, we
take the square of this.
And now the optimal linear
estimator is defined as one
for which these mean squared
error is smallest possible
over all choices of a and b.
So we want to minimize
this expression
over all a's and b's.
How do we do this
minimization?
Well this is a square,
you can expand it.
Write down all the terms in the
expansion of the square.
So you're going to get
the term expected
value of Theta squared.
You're going to get
another term--
a squared expected value of X
squared, another term which is
b squared, and then you're
going to get to
various cross terms.
What you have here is really a
quadratic function of a and b.
So think of this quantity that
we're minimizing as some
function h of a and b, and it
happens to be quadratic.
How do we minimize a
quadratic function?
We set the derivative of this
function with respect to a and
b to 0, and then
do the algebra.
After you do the algebra you
find that the best choice for
a is this 1, so this is the
coefficient next to X. This is
the optimal a.
And the optimal b corresponds
of the constant terms.
So this term and this times that
together are the optimal
choices of b.
So the algebra itself is
not very interesting.
What is really interesting is
the nature of the result that
we get here.
If we were to plot the result on
this particular example you
would get the curve that's
something like this.
It goes through the middle
of this diagram
and is a little slanted.
In this example, X and Theta
are positively correlated.
Bigger values of X generally
correspond to
bigger values of Theta.
So in this example the
covariance between X and Theta
is positive, and so our estimate
can be interpreted in
the following way: The expected
value of Theta is the
estimate that you would come up
with if you didn't have any
information about Theta.
If you don't make any
observations this is the best
way of estimating Theta.
But I have made an observation,
X, and I need to
take it into account.
I look at this difference, which
is the piece of news
contained in X?
That's what X should
be on the average.
If I observe an X which is
bigger than what I expected it
to be, and since X and Theta
are positively correlated,
this tells me that Theta should
also be bigger than its
average value.
Whenever I see an X that's
larger than its average value
this gives me an indication
that theta should also
probably be larger than
its average value.
And so I'm taking that
difference and multiplying it
by a positive coefficient.
And that's what gives
me a curve here that
has a positive slope.
So this increment--
the new information contained
in X as compared to the
average value we expected
apriori, that increment allows
us to make a correction to our
prior estimate of Theta, and
the amount of that correction is
guided by the covariance of
X with Theta.
If the covariance of X with
Theta were 0, that would mean
there's no systematic relation
between the two, and in that
case obtaining some information
from X doesn't
give us a guide as to how to
change the estimates of Theta.
If that were 0, we would
just stay with
this particular estimate.
We're not able to make
a correction.
But when there's a non zero
covariance between X and Theta
that covariance works as a
guide for us to obtain a
better estimate of Theta.
How about the resulting
mean squared error?
In this context turns out that
there's a very nice formula
for the mean squared
error obtained from
the best linear estimate.
What's the story here?
The mean squared error that we
have has something to do with
the variance of the original
random variable.
The more uncertain our original
random variable is,
the more error we're
going to make.
On the other hand, when the two
variables are correlated
we explored that correlation
to improve our estimate.
This row here is the correlation
coefficient
between the two random
variables.
When this correlation
coefficient is larger this
factor here becomes smaller.
And our mean squared error
become smaller.
So think of the two
extreme cases.
One extreme case is when
rho equal to 1 --
so X and Theta are perfectly
correlated.
When they're perfectly
correlated once I know X then
I also know Theta.
And the two random variables
are linearly related.
In that case, my estimate is
right on the target, and the
mean squared error
is going to be 0.
The other extreme case is
if rho is equal to 0.
The two random variables
are uncorrelated.
In that case the measurement
does not help me estimate
Theta, and the uncertainty
that's left--
the mean squared error--
is just the original
variance of Theta.
So the uncertainty in Theta
does not get reduced.
So moral--
the estimation error is a
reduced version of the
original amount of uncertainty
in the random variable Theta,
and the larger the correlation
between those two random
variables, the better we can
remove uncertainty from the
original random variable.
I didn't derive this formula,
but it's just a matter of
algebraic manipulations.
We have a formula for
Theta hat, subtract
Theta from that formula.
Take square, take expectations,
and do a few
lines of algebra that you can
read in the text, and you end
up with this really neat
and clean formula.
Now I mentioned in the beginning
of the lecture that
we can do inference with Theta's
and X's not just being
single numbers, but they could
be vector random variables.
So for example we might have
multiple data that gives us
information about X.
There are no vectors here, so
this discussion was for the
case where Theta and X were just
scalar, one-dimensional
quantities.
What do we do if we have
multiple data?
Suppose that Theta is still a
scalar, it's one dimensional,
but we make several
observations.
And on the basis of these
observations we want to
estimate Theta.
The optimal least mean squares
estimator would be again the
conditional expectation of
Theta given X. That's the
optimal one.
And in this case X is a
vector, so the general
estimator we would use
would be this one.
But if we want to keep things
simple and we want our
estimator to have a simple
functional form we might
restrict to estimator that are
linear functions of the data.
And then the story is
exactly the same as
we discussed before.
I constrained myself to
estimating Theta using a
linear function of the data,
so my signal processing box
just applies a linear
function.
And I'm looking for the best
coefficients, the coefficients
that are going to result
in the least
possible squared error.
This is my squared error, this
is (my estimate minus the
thing I'm trying to estimate)
squared, and
then taking the average.
How do we do this?
Same story as before.
The X's and the Theta's get
averaged out because we have
an expectation.
Whatever is left is just a
function of the coefficients
of the a's and of b's.
As before it turns out to
be a quadratic function.
Then we set the derivatives of
this function of a's and b's
with respect to the
coefficients, we set it to 0.
And this gives us a system
of linear equations.
It's a system of linear
equations that's satisfied by
those coefficients.
It's a linear system because
this is a quadratic function
of those coefficients.
So to get closed-form formulas
in this particular case one
would need to introduce vectors,
and matrices, and
metrics inverses and so on.
The particular formulas are not
so much what interests us
here, rather, the interesting
thing is that this is simply
done just using straightforward
solvers of
linear equations.
The only thing you need to do
is to write down the correct
coefficients of those non-linear
equations.
And the typical coefficient
that you would
get would be what?
Let say a typical quick
equations would be --
let's take a typical
term of this
quadratic one you expanded.
You're going to get the terms
such as a1x1 times a2x2.
When you take expectations
you're left with a1a2 times
expected value of x1x2.
So this would involve terms such
as a1 squared expected
value of x1 squared.
You would get terms such as
a1a2, expected value of x1x2,
and a lot of other terms
here should have a too.
So you get something that's
quadratic in your
coefficients.
And the constants that show up
in your system of equations
are things that have to do with
the expected values of
squares of your random
variables, or products of your
random variables.
To write down the numerical
values for these the only
thing you need to know are the
means and variances of your
random variables.
If you know the mean and
variance then you know what
this thing is.
And if you know the covariances
as well then you
know what this thing is.
So in order to find the optimal
linear estimator in
the case of multiple data you do
not need to know the entire
probability distribution
of the random
variables that are involved.
You only need to know your
means and covariances.
These are the only quantities
that affect the construction
of your optimal estimator.
We could see this already
in this formula.
The form of my optimal estimator
is completely
determined once I know the
means, variance, and
covariance of the random
variables in my model.
I do not need to know how the
details distribution of the
random variables that
are involved here.
So as I said in general, you
find the form of the optimal
estimator by using a linear
equation solver.
There are special examples
in which you can
get closed-form solutions.
The nicest simplest estimation
problem one can think of is
the following--
you have some uncertain
parameter, and you make
multiple measurements
of that parameter in
the presence of noise.
So the Wi's are noises.
I corresponds to your
i-th experiment.
So this is the most common
situation that you encounter
in the lab.
If you are dealing with some
process, you're trying to
measure something you measure
it over and over.
Each time your measurement
has some random error.
And then you need to take all
your measurements together and
come up with a single
estimate.
So the noises are assumed to be
independent of each other,
and also to be independent
from the
value of the true parameter.
Without loss of generality we
can assume that the noises
have 0 mean and they have
some variances that we
assume to be known.
Theta itself has a prior
distribution with a certain
mean and the certain variance.
So the form of the
optimal linear
estimator is really nice.
Well maybe you cannot see it
right away because this looks
messy, but what is it really?
It's a linear combination of
the X's and the prior mean.
And it's actually a weighted
average of the X's and the
prior mean.
Here we collect all of
the coefficients that
we have at the top.
So the whole thing is basically
a weighted average.
1/(sigma_i-squared) is the
weight that we give to Xi, and
in the denominator we have the
sum of all of the weights.
So in the end we're dealing
with a weighted average.
If mu was equal to 1, and all
the Xi's were equal to 1 then
our estimate would also
be equal to 1.
Now the form of the weights that
we have is interesting.
Any given data point is
weighted inversely
proportional to the variance.
What does that say?
If my i-th data point has a lot
of variance, if Wi is very
noisy then Xi is not very
useful, is not very reliable.
So I'm giving it
a small weight.
Large variance, a lot of error
in my Xi means that I should
give it a smaller weight.
If two data points have the
same variance, they're of
comparable quality,
then I'm going to
give them equal weight.
The other interesting thing is
that the prior mean is treated
the same way as the X's.
So it's treated as an additional
observation.
So we're taking a weighted
average of the prior mean and
of the measurements that
we are making.
The formula looks as if the
prior mean was just another
data point.
So that's the way of thinking
about Bayesian estimation.
You have your real data points,
the X's that you
observe, you also had some
prior information.
This plays a role similar
to a data point.
Interesting note that if all
random variables are normal in
this model these optimal linear
estimator happens to be
also the conditional
expectation.
That's the nice thing about
normal random variables that
conditional expectations
turn out to be linear.
So the optimal estimate and the
optimal linear estimate
turn out to be the same.
And that gives us another
interpretation of linear
estimation.
Linear estimation is essentially
the same as
pretending that all random
variables are normal.
So that's a side point.
Now I'd like to close
with a comment.
You do your measurements and
you estimate Theta on the
basis of X. Suppose that instead
you have a measuring
device that's measures X-cubed
instead of measuring X, and
you want to estimate Theta.
Are you going to get to
different a estimate?
Well X and X-cubed contained
the same information.
Telling you X is the
same as telling you
the value of X-cubed.
So the posterior distribution
of Theta given X is the same
as the posterior distribution
of Theta given X-cubed.
And so the means of these
posterior distributions are
going to be the same.
So doing transformations through
your data does not
matter if you're doing optimal
least squares estimation.
On the other hand, if you
restrict yourself to doing
linear estimation then using a
linear function of X is not
the same as using a linear
function of X-cubed.
So this is a linear estimator,
but where the data are the
X-cube's, and we have a linear
function of the data.
So this means that when you're
using linear estimation you
have some choices to make
linear on what?
Sometimes you want to plot your
data on a not ordinary
scale and try to plot
a line through them.
Sometimes you plot your data
on a logarithmic scale, and
try to plot a line
through them.
Which scale is the
appropriate one?
Here it would be
a cubic scale.
And you have to think about
your particular model to
decide which version would be
a more appropriate one.
Finally when we have multiple
data sometimes these multiple
data might contain the
same information.
So X is one data point,
X-squared is another data
point, X-cubed is another
data point.
The three of them contain the
same information, but you can
try to form a linear
function of them.
And then you obtain a linear
estimator that has a more
general form as a
function of X.
So if you want to estimate your
Theta as a cubic function
of X, for example, you can set
up a linear estimation model
of this particular form and find
the optimal coefficients,
the a's and the b's.
All right, so the last slide
just gives you the big picture
of what's happening in Bayesian
Inference, it's for
you to ponder.
Basically we talked about three
possible estimation methods.
Maximum posteriori, mean squared
error estimation, and
linear mean squared error
estimation, or least squares
estimation.
And there's a number of standard
examples that you
will be seeing over and over in
the recitations, tutorial,
homework, and so on, perhaps
on exams even.
Where we take some nice priors
on some unknown parameter, we
take some nice models for the
noise or the observations, and
then you need to work out
posterior distributions in the
various estimates and
compare them.